we look to a company like quest we see a
sort of we see a remarkable story I
would encourage everyone to look up this
story online and essentially is the
following which is that the CEO of quest
was essentially told you need to comply
with the warrantless wiretapping program
and of course he understood the
Constitution he understood that the
warrantless wiretapping program was of
course unconstitutional and of course
illegal and of course being done in
extreme circumstances but that he didn't
want anything to do with it now I don't
know if he's a good guy or a bad guy and
I don't really believe in good or bad
guys but it is very clear that what
happened next is that because he dared
to resist the US government nailed him
for insider trading and the reason that
they got him for insider trading is that
they said effectively that he knew that
he was going to lose some government
contracts and retribution for daring to
resist the warrantless wiretapping
program and since he sold some of his
stock with the knowledge of having
resisted this warrantless wiretapping
program they put him in jail and he only
got out last year so there's a strong
incentive for companies to collaborate
with the state